I'm about to do it Oh Dan I bet to get
out onto the cross here we go
do it Jesus do it oh no oh no oh oh
that's really vice oh god he's covered
in blood
hi Rob handler e hi Danny you know my
friend oh so good it's great to be back
in the world of the grand theft auto
online it really is amazing and seven
Cameron are currently too busy
celebrating Easter know we're gonna do
the same thing and we're gonna do a very
Easter Jesus themed episode of GTA
Diaries hmm
that's why I've prepared a challenge do
you want another challenge yeah late on
me I'm so glad by the way that you
already dressed up as Jesus I also did
my Jesus a little bit more modern yeah
he's got a kind of shaved head and was
wearing a change yeah it looks so great
Laquisha gave me a little snip snip so
I'm looking at pretty Jesus here here so
our challenge today is to basically
reenact in some sort of manner yeah the
crucifixion and rebirth of our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ
very appropriate so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna do three classic parts of
that story of the Easter story number
one we have the Last Supper mmm-hmm to
drive from here the desert mmm you know
nothing says the Middle East like
pumping oil cue shot yeah we have that
we're gonna drive from here into Los
Santos which we will now refer to as
Jerusalem okay yeah we have to go have
our Last Supper which means we have to
go to a convenience store or somesuch
and purchase food it sounds well right
from there we are going to have to go to
a garden like the Garden of Gethsemane
ah we're gonna have to be kissed by
somebody because Jesus Judas I go a
Leicester yeah but where we're going to
have to be kissed by somebody because
Judas of course kissed Jesus in the
Garden of Gethsemane right that's how
the Romans knew who he was and after
that then we are going to go to the
crucifixion the most important part of
the bath story so what we're going to do
is want to find a church and you have to
get to the top of a cross okay on a
church okay
that sounds right if we would get kissed
somehow in a garden by a stranger and
then go go to a church that sounds good
I'm gonna start in three two one go go
go
KQ god damn it all right and we're off
go with Christ good luck
it's too hot out here getting a sick
time you
it's gonna be one of those really
awkward towns that were when I'm naked
mm-hmm my butt's gonna be all pale god
this truck is so hot so Jesus
oh Jesus sees a pickup truck to move all
this stuff but you on the other hand you
looks like you got the minivan see
probably fit most of the disciples in
that yeah I could I could fit I can fit
how many like seven or eight of the yeah
the boys Jesus what do you feel like
today well maybe some snacks they better
have diet that's for sure
hi lady I'm looking for some snacks it's
me Jesus what do you recommend I love
your hair
all right I've seem to be in that
central Jerusalem
whoa I'm there also appears to be some
sort of romantic sake no Rockets look at
that oh god I shouldn't take the Lord's
name in vain but I guess I can't because
I on him get this stupid Roman off of me
hello so what do you recommend for me
it's Jesus you know what you did Jesus
talk about Judas
you just killed Jesus you idiot okay
Jesus how about some pizza and a pack of
smokes you wouldn't buy it you just buy
bottles of water and turn it yourself
oh that's obviously I don't think the
story offers water and of course it
doesn't
of course I rockstar games it's beer and
coal and that's it well sir thank you so
much I definitely cleaned you out so uh
just gonna need some extra bucks I know
you have some cuz I gave you some money
so oh your oh what was that do you know
who you do you know you're talking to
Jesus good oh that's three stars that's
not good no Jesus only likes one star in
the north
shoot hello sir I know yes I know I'm a
different Jesus that Jesus who stole you
earlier was a real dick can I just have
from my last supper a meteoroid bar
please I have an energy bar that's all
about me and a pack of smokes oh you dog
you it watch your figure all right so
now we're both looking to get to a park
so we can clear our a stranger
I'm not quite like you know nothing holy
I guess right because he knew Judas when
we're gonna try and kiss a stranger
there's no kiss button in this video
game right real thought oh so we're
gonna have to we have to figure
something you might have to improvise
yeah
you can't kiss him punch him so mom said
why I'm single I'm gonna hit up a bride
with this guy do it Jesus was probably a
hitchhiker yeah let's be honest yeah I
mean who knows who's in that card might
be Zacharias the tax collector this guy
is probably a little annoyed because
little did he know I had three stars on
he know he's accomplice all right I
found the next best thing to a park a
golf course I'm gonna find something to
kiss on this is that somebody is that so
I can't out it's so dark now it's a
bench why won't anyone kiss me oh I
think I just found my guy
technically Karen's got that I gotta try
kissing before you though I'm gonna take
my time with this one oh hey babe he's
mine hey you stay away from him other
Jesus so what time you off tonight you
want to just you got away from him he's
nice man my man's big he's my man oh you
know we had some times is that because
Oh kiss me what it's gone
I'm kissing him with my fist and then my
foot all right oh okay well I have to
get something else that because you
murdered him thanks babe we a good time
oh this guy I'm gonna kiss this guy okay
I'm a [ __ ] I'm a kiss there you go
right in the kisser I'm gonna steal your
car Jesus thank you Hey bye-bye you have
my crappy car all right so the final
part of this challenge we have to find a
church and whoever can get onto the top
of the church hmm and die wins well
that's easy an Easter challenge well
Danny I'm here and you are stallin so I
got enough time to have a little snack
and I'm gonna do that right now
mmm it wasn't really your last supper
earlier than was it no it's my it's my
second supper I am putting these things
away it's like my sixth beer
it's gonna make climbing on top of that
chairs really you've got a bit of time
on me but don't take it for granted a
red hat for Jesus and a school bass head
to meet Jesus you better try and get on
top of that church pretty soon dude
because I'm using my Oh magical flying
Jesus bars to get the jump on you Jesus
Christ
alright Jesus listen it's your last year
you usually shouldn't climb up people's
houses but this is your house it is so
it's okay all right here ah man I man
damn it
oh do you think I'm about to do it oh
damn I bet to get out onto the cross
here we go do it Jesus do it oh that's
really vice you've got the jump on me
now don't fall off jeath up thank you
Jesus all right man catching up a gym on
the roof I can see that crosses okay so
here oh oh oh man you got up there
there's another way to get up here and
look at you over there I can see you
from here I could see you from here
oh my cool shades must have fallen off
whatever Jesus you still look pretty hot
Oh have you one there yo indeed oh my
God God is right all right
congratulations Rob Jesus in the moon
you want it you got on top I shared a so
I think there's you know there's only
one way this story ends take me Lord
take me
happy Easter everybody Easter how lovely
Oh